what's up guys i'm q and today i'm going
to be challenging my three best friends
blake shawn and andrew to see who can
improve their split the most over the
next week we're going to be following an
article from women's magazine
to give us exercises monday through
sunday and the loser of this challenge
is going to have to eat the hottest chip
in the world
there's some dude foaming at the mouth
after he ate this chip so
i don't want no problem foaming at the
mouth he's like there's snot coming out
and stuff bro
like this is this is gonna be rough
just push back
so where do we measure do we go to life
that'd be so easy this might be easy
yeah he's trying to get lower
how much 10 and a half inches
oh oh yeah everybody's working in line
he's also learning to dump
he's faking he can go lower you go lower
nah that's it bro my leg is so tight
this this this is right here y'all look
really good
nine inches it's not bad that's what she
said
literally nine inches all right y'all
said first knee down and then you just
slide up the first this other leg right
yeah i'm at 12 inches bro
the ballerina snacks are coming off he's
right here which is why i will save you
guys
from the [ __ ] i get a full peel too
no i did a football too 11.5
did sean lewis you got to eat it in his
ballerina socks
back today for day two of trying
to uh rip my scrotum day two sit on the
floor with both legs straight in front
of you
feet flex hinge your body forward with a
straight spine
day two in the books uh
that wasn't too bad wasn't too good
either
i've been losing inches so i started off
at 12.
i aggressively stretched the next day
and i got to 11 and now i'm at like two
feet
so i think we're going the wrong way i
think i must like skip a day because i
feel like i need to like heal or
something
those shorts are too tight it's my legs
i hope they rip i'm sure the guys are
doing just as poorly as me blake blake
doesn't stand to change
blake i play blade gun do worse than me
i know it like blake he don't look
flexible hey andrew he's a dad so you
know
his legs are probably out of commission
already i'm not worried about back there
any advice
on how to do a good split don't rip your
pants
thank you
i'm getting a little worried because i
am not
good with spicy food like spicy food is
not my
my my thing it's
pretty rough
[Music]
all right so just finished it is four
days in and
i feel like not much is improving my
thighs feel like they're still on fire
but uh on the bright side look at this
backdrop
all right so it's day five um starting
off forearms
and knees i don't know if i can go any
lower
your butt looks subpar as per usual as
per use
this one this one hurry for real yo i'm
trying to get nervous
[Music]
oh jesus
christ if i do lose you're gonna see me
die
on camera eating that chip and y'all
don't want to see
for day that i thought i would change up
the scenery and came over to the
local park here and do some weird
stretching [ __ ]
okay like that okay
i don't feel good i feel like i'm going
to be eating the chip i think then maybe
i'm going to get an
inch this is possible
uh hope that at the end of this
i'm not the one eating the world's ship
because it's my birthday weekend
i really don't want to have bubble guts
the whole time
[Music]
wait what in the world
look right now
[Laughter]
yeah why are you wearing the socks again
hey chill out with the socks all right
these are these are my stretching socks
all right
relax it's gonna be closed we're getting
closer
ten and a
is one chip all right just you didn't
get it over with it's not that bad
yeah it's not gonna be that bad bro for
real all right here we go
you got it i feel like he's faking him
oh god i'm not right now
okay now i feel bad
is it that bad it's pretty bad guys
then and it burns really bad like that
particular spot
he crying
whoa guys
[Laughter]
you think you can do better no this one
but this one's for you now
i think that i can handle this a little
better than you are and i don't even
like hot food
i eat hot food i'm haitian i do this my
breakfast is hot
i was three years old eating hot wings i
could eat that chick no problem
and i won't need a bowl of ice cubes to
do it do it
[Music]
you